welcome back to the program we are
hearing from folks in the audience at 6
1 7 8 3 0 47 50 I see that Erin the
trucker is holding and I want to get
caught up with what's going on with him
hey Erin how are things well pretty much
like the last time oh it sounds like
you're on the running um now just so you
know since the last time I called there
have been changes in trucking okay
anyone who's hauling food or groceries
of any kind we are now exempt from our
normal regulation Wow any I can drive
pretty much as long as I want to and I
although you can tell that this system
wasn't really thought all the way
through because as I've experienced
myself if your appointment is still an
appointment time like a specific time
that you have to be it is delivery being
able to drive as long as you want isn't
exactly going to help you that much
right so let me make sure I watched all
the way through
let me let me make sure I understand
that so if I understand correctly a lot
of times the places that you are
delivering stuff to via truck they have
a limited number of loading docks and
things are scheduled out so if you are
allowed to drive as long as you want and
you show up four hours earlier you might
still have to wait four hours for your
loading dock to become available is that
right so you can't just show up to
wherever you want to whatever you want
to do that simply other places it's on
it but it's bare its but do you think
that it's causing drivers to behave on
safely being able to drive as long as
they want I mean aside from the one
article I read last night of a CRS D
driver who drove it to a lake because he
fell asleep behind the wheel so far it
seems like most truckers are actually
using their brain yeah and behaving in a
way that is somewhat intelligent right
right right no for the most part though
speaking of using your brain that leads
me to my question now I considered you
the most level-headed person on Wow
I don't consider out I don't consider
myself to be on the left I consider
myself a man this is one thing I want to
ask you because I trust you to give the
fair's answer please everybody thinks
that they know what the problem with
America I don't I have no delusions of
grandeur okay I know I don't know much
all I can do give you are the things the
way I the way I see it the biggest
problem with America is that the
American people have but too much of
their responsibility to think on the
government and not on themselves which
might explain the reason why so many
people rely on mainstream media to
basically tell them what the thing I
don't agree with that I feel like people
should think of himself my question is I
can only justify being outraged and
putting in all this energy to care about
other people for so long obviously Trump
was it the trigger that finally made
people wake up and it's starting to look
like the coronavirus and all of the
nonsense that goes around with the
throat of iris it's been going to be the
trigger that gets people to wake up
right so my question to you is in your
own words if you even can which I
wouldn't be surprised how do I justify
continuing to care about other Americans
what other Americans don't seem to care
enough about themselves
so let me give you here's this is
beautiful let's imagine that you you're
not empathetic you don't care about
other people you're just concerned with
yourself you should still act in a way
that accounts for other people because
you live in a world of 7 billion people
and unless you are literally going to
isolate yourself in the Northwest
Territories of Canada trapping mink and
living off of frozen berries your life
is going to be better or worse based on
what other people are doing and how
other people are doing so you can take a
complete say like I don't
care about other people beyond how it
affects me you live in a society and if
things are worse off for everybody
they're gonna be worse off for you as
well so from even even if you're just
selfish
we still need to care about other people
sure that's not I mean I would I don't
want to keep too long hobbies do you
have thousands of people want to talk to
people I would just say hump until this
point my life is pretty much unaffected
by the coronavirus my life is conceived
youth has normal and I'm just getting to
a point now where I believe in helping
those who help themselves
call me conservative I don't care well I
believe in helping those who help
themselves
and if Americans are going to continue
to sit down and allow all of these
people with all of this power to just
continue to do whatever the hell they
want then I just can't continue to
justify having all of this anger and all
of this outrage at the things that
happened I'm sorry if that makes me a
bad person and I guess I'm a bad person
it makes you a terrible person Erin
that's exactly right it makes you a
terrible person
no listen I did I understand your
perspective but before you go I I just
have two other trucking questions for
you if I may do okay I know you don't do
this because you said last time you
don't but what do other truckers use to
stay awake into the night is it caffeine
does it is it caffeine pills does it
escalate into other stimulants what do
people use for staying awake while
driving I've seen everything you can
imagine people some people feed some
people drink for Monster energy drinks I
highly don't recommend other people chew
gum which is something that I've taken
up again it varies but most of the time
it hits me stimulants is mostly energy
drink kaya got it okay and last question
my high school physics teacher drove
trucks on the weekends and said many
truckers carry guns because some of the
the loading dock areas are unsafe but
that he doesn't in your experience what
percentage of long-haul truckers are
carrying guns
in my experience I would say less than
1% laughing oh these days tell you yes
the thing is most places these days will
tell you shipper and receiver guns are
not allowed on this premise guys
obviously it's the stone ass Don't Tell
type of deal because unless they're
gonna search your old truck they're not
going out
but in my experience less than 1% less
than 1% got it all right Arabi be safe
out there I appreciate the call
take care same thing all right we'll see
you there there is Aaron the trucker
great to hear from him